bon on descend encore d'un étage mais on
reste dans l'industrie fromagère avec le
grunge la légende veut que ce terme
désigne non seulement un style musical
mais aussi la crème qui se niche entre
les orteils sales bon apparemment il y a
que les Français qui appellent ça comme
ça par contre on est néerlandais on dit
tu es une casse littéralement fromage
d'orteil
peu importe comment ça s'appelle mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette matière et
un mélange de transpiration et de peau
morte qu'on passait un certain temps
enfermé dans des chaussettes et des
chaussures bien macérer et qu'on finit
par être colonisé par des bactéries qui
trouvent tout ce dont elles ont besoin
pour vivre et qui sont responsables de
l'odeur on retrouve des staphylocoques
des microcosus et même des brevis
bactérium qui sont de la même famille
que celles utilisées pour la fabrication
de certains fromages comme le Maroilles
le Munster ou la rac